Good evening, everybody.
And welcome.
My name is Shannon
Rose McAuliffe.
And I'm the Manager of
the Student Arts Programs
here at MIT.
I'm also joined by my
colleague Stacy DeBartolo.
Do you want to
give a quick intro?
Sure.
My name is Stacy DeBartolo.
And I do Finance and
Operations for the Arts at MIT.
And I'm also the Manager of
the Student Art Association.
So both Stacy and
I work with a lot
of these really fantastic and
engaged members of the MIT Arts
programs.
Stacy and I will be co-hosting
this event this evening.
I'll have to be leaving
a little bit early
because I'm also
hosting another event.
So Stacy and I'll be tossing the
talking stick back and forth.
But in the meantime,
before we get underway,
I'd like to remind
everybody here
that this event
is being recorded.
And it may be made
publicly available
on the Arts on the Radar website
or elsewhere in the future.
So if you don't wish to
appear in the recording,
please make sure that
your video and your audio
are muted during the event.
And you can always feel free to
contact us at Arts on the Radar
at MIT dot edu if you
have any questions
or concerns about this.
So moving right along, thank
you all so much for being here
this evening.
We're really excited to hear
from this quite estimable panel
of students and recent alums
who have been deeply involved
in the Arts at MIT.
These students are some of
the most active and engaged
members of this hustling
and bustling arts community.
Their interests span music,
dance, visual arts, journalism,
sort of anything
you can think of.
So this evening, we've
got Ethan Nevidomsky
moderating our panel.
Ethan's a junior.
And he's majoring in Comparative
Media Studies and Computer
Science and Engineering.
He's also an arts scholar.
And with that, I'm going
turn things over to Ethan
to get things rolling.
So hi, everyone.
It's nice to see you all.
And so, we're going
to be going through.
And obviously, thanks
for joining us.
We're going to start
the evening with Julia.
Each member is going
to get five minutes.
And at the end, we'll
have a Q&A. So feel free,
if you have something
that comes to you,
you can probably
drop it in the chat.
But just remember, there
will be time for questions.
So no need to interrupt
while people are presenting.
With that, let's go to Julia.
What do you have for us?
Cool.
Well, hi, everyone.
I'm Julia Chatterjee.
I'm a junior studying Mechanical
Engineering or Course II.
I'm currently in the
process of moving
into this windowless
room in Cambridge
with my old floor
mates from my dorm.
So that's been fun.
But I guess a little bit
about me and Arts at MIT.
Before I got to MIT, I
wouldn't say I was super
involved with the arts.
Fashion was always something
that really interested me.
But I deemed it a frivolous,
I don't know, hobby, I guess.
And I definitely thought there'd
be zero conversation about it
at a place like MIT.
And I was definitely
wrong about that.
But anyway, I was really
lucky that I found myself
in the Freshman Art
Seminar run by Stacy
because I learned about so
many arts opportunities at MIT
that I had no idea existed.
To name a few, The
Lending, the Slap, which
they are not doing this year.
But you get to take
home pieces of art.
And I've done it for
the past two years.
The ceramic studio, the
glass blowing studio.
I got access to
arts classes over IP
for free that everyone else
had to pay like $100 for.
So that was super cool.
And also through that
seminar, I learned
about fashion
opportunities that I've
gotten involved with
my freshman year
and have been involved
with ever since.
So one is the Trashion Show,
which is an annual fashion
show put on by the Undergraduate
Association on Sustainability.
And it features garments
made of upcycled materials
from designers all over
the Boston community.
And if you look up MIT
Trashion Show on YouTube,
there's a video
featuring me, but also
really cool designs that you
should definitely check out.
And last winter, I guess, I
was the project lead for it.
So I got to reach out to
a lot of cool designers.
And it was super cool to see
dress made of wires and trash
bags.
And I feel like the
event has gained
popularity in the past years.
I believe it will have some
virtual form this winter,
as well.
So be on the lookout for that.
But the other thing I
got really involved in
was the Infinite Magazine, which
is MIT's 90s fashion and design
publication.
And when I first joined
my freshman year,
I really had no idea
what I was doing.
I didn't have much
graphic design experience.
But I just always knew that
the magazine was something
that I wanted to be a part of.
And every semester, I just felt
like I needed to contribute.
So, since my freshman year, I've
knit a bra for that magazine
and made earrings out of fruit.
And now, I'm the Editor
in Chief for this issue.
So I'm super excited about that.
We're making another
virtual issue.
And I did want to
share my screen
to show what I made
this past issue six.
So what I ended up
doing is, I initially,
when we were still
on campus in January,
I just knew I wanted
to make pants.
But I didn't know why.
And then when I got home,
because of quarantine and MIT
closing, I found all
these really cool fabrics
in my closet and decided that,
as a reaction to this one size
fits all, everyone leave
and everybody put on a mask
situation that we
were just thrown into,
I made one size fits all pants.
And I had everyone I
was quaranting with
or my friend who wasn't
seeing anyone model them.
And so, this is my
sister's boyfriend.
And then that's my friend.
And then my dad also
got in on the fun.
But I wanted to show this
because, as I mentioned,
we're making another
virtual issue this fall.
And I found that making when
you're in a virtual world
is something that I
found really therapeutic.
And I always felt like I was
really unproductive when I
was quarantining or isolating.
And so, making things
was a way to show
that I was doing
something with my time
and doing something
that I enjoyed.
So if you're
interested in joining,
follow us on Instagram
at Infinite Magazine.
And we'll be posting
about an info session
that we'll be hosting soon.
Yeah.
And I guess going
forward, at MIT
and getting involved
with the arts,
I definitely don't
want to dismiss fashion
as I did before I got here.
Because there's so much
research in fashion,
whether it's C-sale,
doing robotic knitting,
or Course III doing space suits.
Yeah.
That's all I have.
Thank you.
Great.
OK.
That was really nice.
Thanks.
So moving on, sorry.
Give me a second.
My stuff is also acting up.
Yeah.
So moving on, next we'll
be going to Chucho.
Are you ready to present?
Yeah.
OK, hey-- take it away.
Thank you.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Chucho Ocampo.
I'm an artist and an architect.
I am a second year now at
ACT in the ACT program.
Well, I am here in
Cambridge right now.
And I think that the
question is quite good.
What is it like to be
an artist inside of MIT?
I think it's a huge, I
think it's a huge privilege.
And it's a very fun thing to be.
Because I think-- and maybe
I can speak in regards to ACT
the students, as well--
we as artists tend to
play with a lot of things
and are very curious
about a lot of things
that happen, especially
inside the institution.
So being here means
you get to play
with a lot of these things.
And you get to collaborate, as
well, with a lot of very, very
interesting people.
So I'll say, first of all,
that's kind of the main
or the most attractive
thing, being surrounded
by so many people that are
very willing to share ideas
and just collaborate.
And kind of lending also some
of the tools and the things
they are developing.
And it's back and forth,
which is super interesting,
especially being an
artist that makes stuff.
And it is also inside,
in between Architecture,
Media Lab, ACT has a very
interesting, I think,
space inside of MIT, which
I think is super fun.
Another amazing,
amazing thing is,
I think, the supports and
the funding MIT offers,
especially Arts at MIT
and all of the grants
that are available that are
super precious for production,
which makes prototyping and
making [AUDIO OUT] possible.
And that's not very
common in my experience.
So being inside
this place and also
having the resources available
makes it a completely different
experience.
And also programs such
as the Residency Program
that Arts at MIT
has also relates
to ACT or MISTI that also offers
certain things for artists,
as well.
And yeah, I think,
overall I don't
have like a specific project.
I think just for
the past year, I
have been surrounded in
this crazy environment
but also felt very
much supported.
Not just financially but also
via this really incredible
array of people
and facilitators.
I think that's it.
Really great.
And you were also working
on a collaborative project
with Aarti, right?
Yes.
I think Aarti can jump in.
Yeah.
And feel free to talk together.
Or just let her take over.
One of these things,
especially, I mean, obviously
when you're inside this--
as I was saying--
if you're inside,
you're being supported,
you're building things.
And then COVID hit, of course,
and changed a lot of things.
And so, I think most of us
had to shift media or medium,
and shift towards more
digital platforms or software
or other types of supports.
And we realized we were
working on very similar ideas
altogether.
So we decided to
collaborate and make
a project all of
our cohort together.
And maybe Aarti can tell you
a little bit more about that.
So I don't know.
You're muted, Aarti.
You're muted right now.
Sorry.
Yeah.
So I'm going to quickly
share screen and talk over
that so that you can have
an idea of what exactly
we were doing.
So--
I'm also sharing the link
of the web page in the chats
so you can also go through.
So yeah.
So this is something which, as
Chucho said, the five of us--
we are five of us
in a cohort-- and we
decided that what we had a very
good rapport with each other.
And then we decided we certainly
were in different places
without the kind
of support that we
give each other, which
is very important for us
on our own projects.
And we decided
that we would have
to find a way to work together
regardless of location.
And we came up on this
idea of putting together,
it came off the
exquisite corpse kind
of general conceptual
framework, which
is to be able to put together
different kinds of material
and to construct something
out of different pieces
of multiple things.
I mean, whatever it is that
whoever brings to the table.
So that was this.
So each of us sort of modeled
particular landscapes,
modeled particular items.
Maybe it was a room,
maybe it was a walk,
maybe it was an object.
And we converted
them to models which
we could sort of push and pull
and deconstruct and mix and put
together.
And we sort of created fictional
landscapes, which each of us
were very embodied--
I mean, we were looking for an
embodied kind of relationship
with these landscapes.
So the link to website
is in the chat.
And you can take a look at it.
It's just a couple of
worlds, so to speak.
And you can navigate through it
and sort of experience sound.
You can experience certain
kinds of texts, maybe.
Things that we were working,
the kind of movement
we were interested in.
So this is something
which, I mean
this is the beginnings
of, I think,
a very long term collaboration
between the five of us.
And all these lines
that you see here
are also the traces
that people have left,
the kind of movement people
have created over time.
So this is that.
And so, I'm just going to
stop sharing right now.
I think, if I can jump in,
it's interesting to know,
coming back to the idea of MIT
and how it informs what we do,
this comes also from
some of the experience we
had before with an XR
class and AR photogrammetry
And we're just kind of
taking these ideas, which
can be very technical
sometimes, and we're just
kind of mixing them and making
our own type of exercises.
We're kind of mix
matching these things.
And we're creating
our own method
of collaging, you
could say, which
is kind of what the role
of ACT is, more or less.
Yeah.
No.
Definitely.
It was a very interesting
collaboration.
Because also, it
was the beginning,
I think it's solidified the
beginnings of a very long term
collaboration.
We're already working,
thinking of next projects,
thinking of how [? Gamut ?] can
help fund our next projects.
Because we now are
bursting with ideas.
And that's something
which I think
we were very
privileged to receive
from [? Gamut ?] from TSI,
which is Transmedia Storytelling
Initiative, which we're
all a part of now.
So yeah.
I mean, I need to
introduce myself, though.
I'm Aarti Sunder.
I'm in Cambridge.
I've been here since the
start of COVID and never left.
I was threatening to
leave, but I never left.
And yeah.
I mean I largely work with film.
In the last year, I've
been working with film.
So one of the things that
was really good for me
was to be able to pull
out of art in order
to come back to art.
So I was able to take classes
across MIT and Harvard.
I mean, Harvard,
I'm just trying now.
But across MIT, say
for instance, in LSDS,
in the Labor Department.
It was something which was
very crucial for my exploration
of work and practice
as an artist.
And this is something which
I think I would encourage,
if anyone would were to
join as an artist in MIT,
I would really
encourage that, which
is to be able to look
across departments,
look across campuses, and take
things which you may not think
can help you.
But then it sort of opens
up a lot of ideas simply
because you have experts
in multiple fields
who are really willing to
drop everything and help
the moment you ask a question.
I mean, it's something which
I've been able to bank on,
which I hope that--
if there's an artist whose
is interested, I mean,
I just think it's a
good space to be in.
And I hope that works for
everyone who comes in, as well.
So yeah.
That's basically it.
If there's anything I missed
out on, you can ask me.
If you want to, you can talk
more about your next project.
You said you're working
on a new collaboration?
Oh yeah.
So we're looking at--
OK, we just had a meeting--
[LAUGHTER]
Should I say?
Yeah.
Why not?
OK.
So we're looking
at publishing now.
We're looking at what
kinds, how we can convert
this kind of online
first person interaction,
almost like a gaming
interaction, into a sort
of a publication space.
What would it mean?
What kind of images
are we talking about?
Because one of the things
is online engagement.
But I think, after three days
of Zoom, I think all of us
have sort of a yearning for
a book, a yearning for pages
at some level.
So we're looking at
what kinds of printing
we're interested in,
what kinds of images
we would like to take
offline, what kind of 2D--
maybe pop up, maybe,
we don't know--
but what kind of
publishing platforms
that are maybe online
or maybe it's a hybrid.
We're not quite sure.
But I think we're going to
be jumping into making books
whether it's doing it
like an artist's book
or doing it as something
which can be printed in bulk.
I mean, we're not
quite sure yet.
But we're looking at
what would it mean
to publish in a hybrid format.
What does that even mean?
Do we have books online?
Do we have books offline?
So that's where
our mind is going.
And how do we build on
those fictional landscapes
that we've created?
How do we convert that into
something which is potentially
online, as well as analog?
So that's where we are.
That's really cool.
Keep us posted.
I'm sure everyone's
looking forward to it.
OK.
And then next up, we
have Danny and Alvin.
Danny and Allan, my bad.
Both on the same screen with
a really cool background.
So feel free to unmute
yourself and present.
Hello.
I'm Alan.
And I'm Danny.
So we both are recently
graduated from MIT.
And our majors were Computer
Science and Comparative Media
Studies.
And we're currently both
in Florida right now.
So looking back,
back in high school,
we were always interested
in various forms of arts,
from animation and different
fiber arts, painting,
things like that.
And we were kind of
worried that, at MIT, we
wouldn't be able to pursue
those different forms of art.
But throughout
our course at MIT,
we actually were
happily and unexpectedly
able to pursue all those
different forms of art
that we were hoping to.
So we can show some of the
projects that we worked on.
So I'm going to share my screen.
So first I'll talk about
the very first art project
that we did at MIT.
And then Danny is going
to talk about the last one
that we did right
before graduating.
So this is a project that we
completed in our freshman IP
for this kind of--
it came out of, it kind of
popped up out of nowhere.
It was called Open
Mind, Open Art.
We saw flyers advertising
it in the Student Center.
And we thought it was a
really cool opportunity
to make art during
our freshman IP,
so we decided to
join that project.
The goal of it was
for 10 student artists
to create their own projects
revolving around the theme
of mental health and wellness.
The project was funded by the
Mind, Head, Heart Initiative.
And what we really liked
about this project,
it was also kind of a
community of people.
By the end of the IP, it
was really collaborative.
And everything was
pretty open ended.
We had this general theme about
mental health and wellness.
But besides that,
everyone could take
their projects in whichever
direction they wanted to.
So there were people who
made clay sculptures, people
who made paintings,
someone wrote poetry.
And what we decided to do was
make this fiber arts piece.
So we were really interested
in various forms of fiber arts
in high school, like
knitting, sewing.
So we wanted to kind of
take that a step further.
So what we basically
did for this piece is
sewed a bunch of little
pieces of fabric together,
specifically felt, to create
this series of six faces.
And the idea behind this
was kind of for the viewer
to empathize with the faces
that we depicted here.
And we also kind of made
this little wordplay.
The title of this piece
is "Stitched Together."
So that kind of has
this double meaning
because the pieces are
literally stitched together
out of these pieces of fabric.
But we also kind of wanted
to evoke this feeling
that everyone kind of has either
shared struggles or shared
experiences and can
relate to each other,
even if not initially evident.
So yeah.
That was this experience.
It was overall really fun.
And we were really
happy that we were
able to pursue this
interest in fiber arts
at MIT in our freshman year.
Yeah.
So then moving forward--
also in our freshman
year, actually--
started by a few upperclassmen
called Borderline.
Which-- for those not familiar--
Borderline is a
student group on campus
that's responsible for the
murals in the tunnels of MIT's
campus.
And the murals aren't
just flat images.
They also have an augmented
reality component to them.
So if you put your
phone over them,
you'll see an animation playing.
And this club kind of started
in our freshman spring, as well.
And then, ever since then, we
both joined the organizing team
of the club and have kept
it running ever since,
along with a lot of other
really great students
who have contributed
to the club.
Both on an organizational level
and on an actual art creation
and animation creation level.
So this group kind of started
off as just this project
that I think was
initially just intended
to be one semester long.
But then, it just
kept on growing.
And people just kept on
being interested in it.
And it became an official club.
So this most recent
project that we
did before graduating
was a project that we
did with members of the
Borderline community,
where some of the
some of our members
decided to, after
getting sent home, we
wanted to find a way
to still create art
together and connect.
So what they did was
they created this website
that was supposed to
be a virtual recreation
of the tunnels where
students can submit drawings
of their quarantine rooms.
And the drawings can
be really creative.
So it doesn't necessarily
have to be like a normal room.
But it could be imaginative.
So this is just a scroll
through of the website.
And then our particular
contribution to this project
was that we added [INAUDIBLE]
in Borderline [INAUDIBLE]..
The screen is loading.
OK.
There it is.
But yeah.
The video's loading.
But anyway, in true
Borderline fashion,
we didn't just want the images
to be just flat pictures.
We wanted to also add an AR
component to the work, as well.
So [? Allan ?] and I worked
on animating some of the CPW--
Campus Preview Weekend
had just been canceled.
For the incoming
freshmen, we also
wanted to have the animations
have a little welcome message
to the students that
were unfortunately
not able to visit campus.
So it was both a way for
students who are currently here
to connect with each other
but also [INAUDIBLE] a way
to kind of reach out students
who were newly admitted.
Virtual workshops for
animation in the way
that we typically would
do in a normal semester.
And it was just something
that initially, I think,
when we first had
to go off campus,
we just thought that
Borderline wasn't really going
to be able to do much,
since so much of what we do
is physically on campus.
Our wall of murals
is in the tunnels.
And a lot of other
projects that we've done
have had to be very
much like on campus.
But we were able to
find this creative way
to create art and
connect with each other,
despite all of that.
And yeah.
And then, I guess one of
the other points that we
wanted to touch on is, I guess,
what we're working on now.
So since quarantine and
we've been home in Miami,
we're trying to
find different ways
to continue learning and
expanding and growing
artistically.
So recently something
that we've been doing
is trying to learn new
skills, like 3D modeling.
So we've just been
following, there
are a lot of free resources
online through YouTube
tutorials and things like that.
So that's kind of what
we've been up to now.
And it's been a really cool
way to learn new things
and kind of expand our
art making possibilities.
Awesome.
Thanks so much.
Yeah, looking forward
to seeing that, too.
3D modeling is really cool.
I think I've been
trying to get into.
But it's really tough.
So it's exciting
to see how it goes.
OK.
And then last, but
obviously not least, is Joy.
Joy, are you ready to present?
Yeah.
Can you hear me?
I can hear you.
OK.
Great.
So a little bit about me.
I'm Joy.
I am a junior in
Courses Six, 14, and 18.
And I just declared my
Music minor last week.
So that's happening.
I'm currently in California.
And I'm here kind of repping
the more music and dance
side of Arts on Campus.
So I guess the most important
part of my campus arts life,
I guess, would be that I'm the
Public Relations Director, as
well as a traditional
choreographer,
for the Asian Dance
Team on campus.
And I will touch upon that
a little bit more later.
I'm also the Ensemble
Director for MIT Cello World,
which is the cello ensemble.
And we just started the
organization last fall.
So we're still relatively new.
And it's meant to be like Cello
World as in like, Hello World.
And the cello ensemble, the
performing ensemble's name,
is called Cello Plus
Plus, shortened to C++,
which I think is cute.
I'm also an Art Scholar,
run by [INAUDIBLE],,
who is absolutely awesome.
And my freshman year, I
played for two semesters
in the MIT Symphony Orchestra.
And my sophomore year,
I played for a semester
in the MIT Chamber
Music Society.
And I played piano and cello,
mostly cello at school.
And I actually wanted to kind of
bring up an exciting initiative
that's happening this fall.
So Cello World is
collaborating with Rhibotones,
which is a MIT's community
service music group.
And we're starting a thing
called the MUSE Project, which
obviously MIT loves acronyms.
So that stands for Music
Unites Songs for Equity.
And it serves to
kind of highlight
the work of Black
and BIPOC, just
BIPOC in general, composers
in the classical music scene.
So that's going to be happening.
We're all going to be recording
from home and audio mixing
and video editing.
And they will be released as a
kind of a series of videos just
to highlight the
diversity that normally
doesn't get highlighted in
the classical music world.
So that's kind of all the stuff
I'm involved in on campus.
A lot of music and dance things.
And I just wanted to share
my screen really quick
and kind of show you some of the
things that ADT has been doing,
Asian Dance Team has been
doing throughout quarantine.
Because obviously dance
is kind of like a,
how do you do that
during quarantine?
Kind of thing.
So really quick, this
was pre quarantine ADT.
All right.
So this is pre-quarantine ADT.
These are some of our
very professionally
filmed and edited and
put together covers.
Some of these we've submitted to
big cover competitions online.
And most of the people you
will see in these videos
came to MIT with absolutely
no background in dance.
They were beginners.
So it's always really
gratifying as a choreographer
to see everyone grow.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
so
So that was pre-quarantine ADT.
And I was actually in the
second to last video there.
I was in the back.
But that video, we
filmed nine takes
from before sunset
to after sunset,
which is how you saw the
color of the sky change, which
I thought was fun.
And this is quarantine ADT.
So in quarantine, ADT is
still doing a full setlist.
Nothing is changing.
All of our rehearsals are
held asynchronously now.
And we also have just on
your own time auditions
where you just send us
videos of you dancing.
And to kind of pub
for the auditions,
we made this cute little kind
of like a viral K Pop challenge
of the song that just dropped.
And I think it's number one
on the pop charts right now
or something.
It's kind of a big deal.
So we had choreographers film
all the videos separately.
And we just edited it together.
And I think it's really cute.
[KPOP MUSIC PLAYING]
Yeah.
So that is what's
going on in my life.
And that is how
I am still trying
to do arts in quarantine.
Great.
Well, now that everybody has
given their little spiel--
and it was great
hearing from everybody--
we can open the
floor to questions.
We don't have too much time.
We've got five minutes.
But if anybody has anything,
feel free to go ahead,
everyone.
And also if anybody on the panel
has any questions for anybody
else, feel free to go ahead.
It's nice to have
some crosstalk.
If nobody directly
has anything, I
think some people talked
directly about this.
But if anybody
else wants to talk
towards how corona
has affected their art
and how they think
they've changed
or kind of addressed
it within their art,
I don't know if anybody
has any specific answers.
But it's something I
think a lot about it
in terms of the
art world and how
it's not just kind of affecting
individuals, which is normally
how crises happen.
But it should be reflected
across, I think, everyone.
I think, in a way,
at least in ACT,
what I'm seeing, for
example, this semester,
is that a lot of
classes are turning
their heads towards the
outside and the city
and out to the experiences.
And I mean, obviously
for practical reasons.
But also how do we continue
artistic research, for example,
which is what ACT does?
How do we continue artistic
research and knowledge?
How do we keep on
giving knowledge
without the facilities?
So this semester is
super interesting.
If you take a look at the
subjects, most of them
are either choreographing
things in the city,
walking, thinking about the
outside, not just the city
but in general.
So I think that it
changed, I mean,
it's a super
positive adaptation.
It changed very quickly.
So I think that's one of
the really nice things we
could get, at least.
It's nice to hear.
Yeah.
You've got to find the
silver linings in everything.
I see that.
Anyone else?
Yeah.
Something I've noticed is that
I've just gotten more excited
about making do with what
I have like seeing how
I can get creative with that.
Like the pants I
showed, I guess.
Or just viewing items that I
have already in a new light
and turning them
into something has,
instead of going
to buy supplies,
has influenced my art.
And I honestly think it's made
it more interesting and more
fruitful.
I think I saw someone in the
audience unmute themselves.
I'm not sure if
you had a question
or if that was accidental.
I do have a question actually.
I wonder how much
everyone's process
has changed in the context
of maybe your process isn't
as private anymore.
Right?
When you had facilities,
you could go into a space,
work on your craft, and
decide when to showcase
what you're working on.
Whereas now, maybe we're
forced in environments ,
whether it's outdoors or in
a house with somebody else,
where you have to go through the
whole process from conception
to refinement in a
less private setting.
And I wonder how that's
impacted, if at all,
people's process and experience.
I mean, I can speak
a little to that.
One of the things which we took
a decision in our cohort in ACT
was that we would
isolate within ourselves.
So we decided that we would make
sure that we saw each other.
And we found a way to
quarantine only with each other
so that we could continue.
I mean, it was very important
for us to work together.
And what happened with corona
was that it sort of accelerated
the process of trying to--
because at some point,
we only had each other.
And that really made--
I mean, that also accelerated
the process of collaboration.
It accelerated the process
of how do we work together,
why are working together?
And what is the importance
of going offline and online?
We needed to
straddle both spaces
with equal forms of engagement,
equal level of engagement.
And the same intensity
and complexity.
So it's something which--
I agree with Chucho in the sense
that the class has shifted.
I think the turning point
for the classes shifting
was when Trump made that
announcement and then
suddenly everyone's panicking.
But that once that sort
of went off the table,
the idea of trying
to go offline did not
go off the table, which
was something very good.
And I mean, in many
ways, it's worked
for the better for a lot of us.
Of course, there are, I mean
shop access, I mean equipment,
these things are
always a problem.
But you have to negotiate
that on a one to one basis.
But in terms of
interaction, to be honest,
I think it brought us a
lot closer with each other.
Because at some
point, we realized
we have to create a community
in a completely different space
all together now.
So different things
are at stake.
Great.
Thanks so much.
Unfortunately-- this
was really great--
but I think that's all
of the time we have.
I think Stacy has a quick
plug for the Gallery Tour.
And then we can wrap up.
Yes.
So our last of Arts on the
Radar event for the evening
is a gallery tour
of Misalignments.
And it's two Masters of
Architecture students
who did their exhibition in
the Online Wiesner Student Art
Gallery.
And so, they created a
series of gallery rooms
that each kind of illuminated
a different aspect
of their robotically
fabricated ceramics.
And so, I will put the Zoom Room
number in the chat right now.
But I hope that you guys
can all join us in there.
Because I think it'll be
a really interesting talk.
And I hope to see you all soon.
I'll put the number in the chat.
Thanks so much, everyone.
It was so good to see you all.
Have a nice night.
Thank you.
Gracias.
Cutting Across the
Archive, From Photo Montage
to Digital Folklore.
This Advanced
Photography course is
designed for students who wish
to explore photography, images,
and archives as
tools and resources
for artistic practices.
The course focuses on the
use of archival images
and photographic practices
while encouraging students
to explore analog,
digital, and [AUDIO OUT]
and new technologies.
Through lectures, readings,
film screenings, student driven
projects, visiting
artist presentations,
and critic sessions,
students experiment
with a range of
artistic strategies
while engaging in cross
disciplinary research
and working in collaborative
and individual assignments.
Across a diverse spectrum of
themes and historical context,
students read and
discuss theoretical texts
related to the use of archives
and artistic practices.
Advanced Video
and Related Media.
This course introduces advanced
strategies of image and sound
manipulation, both
technical and conceptual.
We'll cover everything from
preproduction planning,
storyboards, and
scripting through
the refinement of digital
editing techniques,
visual effects such as
Chroma Key, post-production,
as well as audio and
sonic components.
Context is provided by regular
viewings of contemporary video
artworks and other
audio visual formats.
Video Installation is a
contemporary and expanding art
genre that intersects with
the world of architecture,
engineering, programming,
new media, and performance
practices.
In this intermediate
to advanced course,
students are encouraged to
expand the current themes
and methods within their
art or research practices
by experimenting with
various video installation
strategies, such as video
mapping to 3D objects, site
specific architectural projects,
multi-channel projection
environments,
mixing moving image
content with live performance,
wearable sculptures,
live feeds, physical computing,
or other elements of interest.
[MUSIC PLAYING]